it's really important in this era of
constant sort of political scandal and
in reality it's it's almost an era of
constant scandal fatigue not to let the
storylines of this administration just
fade away without follow-up and one of
those stories is the wall right Donald
Trump's wall with Mexico which we now
learned can be defeated with $100 saw
available at any hardware store
so remember Donald Trump promised a wall
across the entire us-mexico border by
the end of his first term obviously a
joke it's not going to happen it always
was a joke it was never going to happen
but Donald Trump and his followers are
trying to claim that the wall is being
built Trump says it's being built the
truth is that there was previously
approved money to repair and replace
some aged parts of the wall and it is
being done with the version of the wall
that Donald Trump likes or says is quote
virtually impenetrable so another
element of this is the strength of the
wall and the ways in which the wall can
be defeated and it turns out that the
wall Trump wants to build is a total
farce it is not virtually impenetrable
it is very easily defeated and in fact
border agents and officials recently
told The Washington Post that $100 saw
that you can get at any hardware store
can cut right through the wall some of
these rebuilt repaired wall sections
were done with Trump's version of the
wall which has steel bollards and it has
a 30 foot a series of 30 foot tall
panels so smugglers have been carrying
around $100 saw and just cutting through
the steel ball ERDs and then you push
the panels forward and you walked right
through Donald Trump's virtually
impenetrable wall which he called the
rolls-royce of walls it sounds more like
the Trump Tower of walls given its
shoddy nature I think that's the better
analogy for the quality of the
construction that I would use now
unfortunately this is what happens when
you let xenophobia blind you and your
followers you end up putting all of your
eggs in one basket in this case it's the
basket of a wall
all that doesn't really work and in the
basket of obsolete technology that does
nothing to address the underlying
reality of why people are trying to come
to the United States which is really
what we should be working on if we want
to solve this problem but it turns out
that it can also be defeated with a
hundred dollar tool look at anytime in
history and look at the various ways the
myriad ways in which walls have been
defeated look at Troy look at I'm
forgetting other historical examples off
hand but there are many of them now you
can argue the point of the wall isn't
that it has to actually be impenetrable
it just has to delay people long enough
that border patrol can show up wait a
second
you're shifting the goal posts to say
that we're going to spend 20 billion 25
billion whatever it's going to be and
it's not meant to stop $100 saw it's
just meant to delay people so that
Border Patrol can show up doesn't a
river also delay people long enough that
Border Patrol should be able to show up
in all cases because we've already got
that at much of the border the wall is
not pragmatic the wall is a monument to
xenophobia it's a monument to political
promises and it's not being built that's
the most important thing it is quite
literally a boondoggle and by the way
I'll remind you it's not just a hundred
dollars saw that can defeat the wall the
wall has been scaled and passed over as
well but this is also altum Utley not
about that this is an example of
feelings over facts the fact that the
wall will cost tens of billions of
dollars and not solve anything the fact
that the wall can be defeated with a
hundred dollar tool the facts don't
matter the feeling that trumpets get by
seeing Trump talk about the wall and
promise the wall of Trump being big and
strong and powerful and that it'll stop
people cook from coming in in some
complete fantasy world that supersedes
the facts and the people who shout about
we should pay attention to facts over
feelings are the ones who are being
destroyed by their own feelings while
ignoring the facts and yet again another
embarrassment a hundred dollars saw
defeating the
the wall is barely a conversation
anymore for Republicans of course
because it was yet another one of Donald
Trump's massive failures but we're not
going to forget about it
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
Jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on blinka they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa k mas